what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on very excited
to be talking about journey talks we
have Maya Lockwood joining us on the
show hi Maya hi thanks for having me I'm
so excited that this is finally
happening
it's been a long time I think maybe
around four years ago I attended your
journey talks and it was one of the most
important pivotal moments in my life and
it just started expanding me out into a
bunch of different important people and
fields and spiritual processes and I'm
so proud that you know you've had this
this trajectory with your life up until
now with indie bio and I'm really
excited to unpack that with everyone
those who don't know Maya's background
she is the communications director at
Indy bio member of SOS ventures which is
the world's leading biotech accelerator
and you can find the link in the bio
below Maya let's start things off by
talking about what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world oh my
goodness well there's two directions we
could go in there is the one of optimism
hope and there is one of doom and gloom
and so I'm always the eternal optimist
and thinking that we're gonna go in the
direction of light and so that's what
I'm hoping for and what would you say is
a core principle that we need to embody
to get to the direction of the light mmm
go within go within connect with
yourself start to really unpack the
things that are going on within you and
how does one go about that inward
journey there's many paths you know one
of them that we are most well aware of
is meditation and so I'm a big proponent
of meditation sitting in silent
listening to yourself what usually comes
up when they do that or when other
people do that when you talk
them about their experiences sometimes
if you sit long enough he'll become
aware of the voice within your head and
understanding that you're the observer
of this voice and that it's not really
you and that they're the you is
something much bigger what do you think
that you that's much bigger it is I
think it's channelled source channel
from source whatever you may call it
whether it's the universe divine God
goddess life it's different for everyone
your highest self and so that were we're
observing that that channeling process
well you're observing your thoughts I
call it the big you and the little use
the big you is is watching me the little
you chatter talk the big you is this
higher the higher self yes is watching
the little you which is the one that's
in this body yes okay and there's like
kind of like a co-creative process
happening between them
if you're lucky yes you're lucky you
have a co-creative process going with
big your your higher self and your your
other self where you're living in true
alignment with whatever is being
channeled but many of us don't have many
of us aren't living in that alignment so
the more we get into that alignment the
more we have a positive trajectory for
our future absolutely absolutely yes yes
more likely the more we can bring our
unique gifts forward and know ourselves
and then help others with that same
process and drive more of a cohesive
social fabric type of stuff that's the
journey that's the journey
yeah what about your journey no Omega
tell us about where you were born who
you were growing up how you got
interested in what you care about so I
was born in a jungle in Bangladesh which
is very small but populous Islamic
country between Burma and India and
small in terms of land size but not
population wise right it's the size of
Wisconsin population of over a hundred
and sixty-five million people it's very
densely populated and so I was born to a
woman who was tribal and from a
matrilineal tribe that is a small
minority in Bangladesh they pick up
about one person at a population so the
oldest matrilineal tribes left here on
this planet and so she was 14 and she
was sold to my father as a third wife
and he was Muslim and so I was put up
for adoption about five months after I
was born and I was put into a American
family with an American family and so
that's who I grew up with that's my
family and so I spent about the first
fourteen years or so in Southeast Asia
growing up there and my parents worked
in international development and then I
moved to the United States went to
school here and pursued a degree in
communications and political science and
spent a lot of my time interested in
personal growth and eventually led me to
want to find out more about my roots so
I went back to Bangladesh to meet my
mother when I was 33 years old my
biological mother
so that was my big journey and from that
experience a whole new world opened up
into the exploration of
and understand itself and through that
understanding of self I did a lot of
healing and I also became more empowered
and tapped into my own potential Wow
do you remember the those first moments
of life for you with your biological
mother I don't remember but a lot of the
things I'm sure experienced were pre
verbal so I have done a lot of research
and delving into early childhood trauma
and as I as I learned more about myself
I understand that the first year of my
life was very traumatic having been
taken away from my biological mother put
in an orphanage and then put up for
adoption
understanding how my brain was
developing even before I was born in the
womb and responding to various the fear
of my mother and the environment outside
of me Wow and what is some like what is
the what does a mat true lineage would
what is then and how is how do you know
it's like one of the oldest in the world
that type of thing so matrilineal
culture is a culture in which the women
inherit the land and they're called the
garros and they've lived there for you
know thousands of years and inhabited
that particular region the jungle
I think they've like come from Mongolia
originally but I don't know the exact
details but they look very differently
so they have a little more different
they have different features and the
native Bengalis they're lighter skinned
and the women also can marry as many
people as they want to versus the
Bengali Muslims the men get to marry the
as many wives as they want and it's a
patriarchal society so it's quite unique
in the sense that here they have
survived for so long as a minority
within this very densely populated
Islamic country do you know how many
approximately are left in that lineage I
don't know occasionally but they're like
a really big minority about 1% of the
popular one percent of the population
Wow so and and they're the the
indigenous culture of that that area so
as many indigenous cultures across the
world are are left there they're being
pushed out of their native habitat and
in this case the jungle and so a lot of
them are being pushed into the city is
happening there over the world yeah I
wonder what some of the most optimal
practices are from one of the like Metro
Metro lineages versus like a patriarchal
like lineage like what is what could be
some of the benefits of like a female
inheriting the land and like being a
steward of it and having multiple
partners as men versus like what are
some of the ones in a patriarchal
hierarchy like what could be some of the
most cool aspects to like bring together
and be able to I'm feeling but I'm not
certain that it's more cooperative
from what I've witnessed the the Metro
matriarchal societies my cooperative the
women are much prouder to be seen and
heard
and so they walk differently there
they look you in the eye you go a couple
of miles down the road the women are
looking down they're avoiding the gays
you know they feel a little there's a
little bit of a imbalance the energy
there yeah to have women around the
world feeling like they can unleash
their gifts most foully is so critical
and how we get there is
I hope fast and and and also
frictionless and seamless and just
prosperous and Maya what about the
moment for you of having you know you
had a family for 14 years there and did
did they decide to make the move to the
US or how did you decide to make this
move I decided to move to the US I had
been coming here my whole life just
because my parents are American and our
element much of our family lives here
so I decided was I was going to come to
school here yeah yeah okay and then how
about these last couple of years of what
you've been up to because the journey
talks have been so amazing Indy bio is
an incredible organization you know tell
us about these last couple years so when
I returned from Bangladesh oh you
actually met sorry you my mother my
biological yes we should let's talk
about that first yes yes and so so the
big turning point for me was that
experience was was going back into my
past and going deeper into you know who
I was and what I wanted to do with my
voice and my power in this world once I
saw where I came from was that you know
I I wasn't gonna focus my energy on on
Bangladesh I wanted to focus my energy
on creating a new paradigm building any
world versus trying to fix an old world
and so I saw that opportunity and
working with entrepreneurs because
entrepreneurs are doing that they are
innovators they're visionaries they are
seeing a future that has yet to be built
and I wanted to be a part of that
because as [ __ ] monster filler set
fuller says I'm sure I've messed up his
name you know you you can't you know you
have to create a new world build a new
one don't try to fix the old one and so
that's what I want to be a part of I
want to be a part of the world that is
doing just that mm-hmm and so when I
came back to San Francisco I started
working mainly primarily with
entrepreneurs I started the journey
talks for people who were building great
technology and doing big things that
would be impactful to find their deepest
message and be able to share that and
develop that for a global stage what was
what were you feeling when you were
first meeting your biological mother I
was it was a very traumatic experience
for me because I yeah it was it was it
was hard you know I had never met her in
my life and people think it might have
been a joyous occasion and it wasn't it
was it was very scary for both of us you
know could very uncomfortable Wow
I mean there was a lot of pain error so
you know it it helped me to understand
that there's some things in life that
I'm not able to fix I'm not able to fix
people and I'm not able to fix the past
but I can certainly look toward things
that can be created vs6 yeah and then
you guys passed a couple of days
together how long did you guys pass
together
uh we I was there for about a week each
time I'd been several times yes and when
you're passing on time to yo there was
there was some like you said there was
just this like feeling of it's just like
a big thank you this is a biological
mother of yours that you've never met
before that had to that you that that
you it certainly made me think about
nature versus nurture you know how much
of our lives and how we become who we
are is nature and how much of our us is
nurture and I think it's nurture there's
a bit of both but yeah it brought up
those questions and it also really made
me think about what I wanted to do with
my life yes because then at that point
it's like do I help here with this
matriarchal lineage divide yeah yeah do
i mm-hmm or do I go and assist with
these entrepreneurial visionaries and
you just build a new paradigm of the
future and what we're doing in San
Francisco I think there's a lot of good
people here and good people across the
world and so I want to align with those
good people and build with those good
people yeah okay so you're let's talk
about this what you're finding you you
know you're finding people in that you
find to be visionary that have cool
journeys you're having them come and
speak on the stage
that you produce you're also helping the
scientists become entrepreneurs at Indy
bio as well with the visions to solve
some of the world's greatest challenges
with through biotechnology so how are
you identifying the people that you call
visionary and then how are you helping
them mmm so Indy bio we have a team of
six extraordinary people who reviews the
potential investments and so each of my
team members I highly admire and it's
such a great honor to work with them and
so there's a lot of due diligence into
not just the founders but the
technologies they're building and it's a
very intricate process and you know not
only do we look at the science but we
also look at the human the the
entrepreneur who is potentially going to
lead in the future are these people
capable of leading because we not only
help entrepreneurs
sorry scientists become entrepreneurs we
help entrepreneurs become leaders of
movements so if you're familiar with
Memphis meets they were our first cell
based meet investment which we career
the first meatball in our lab which
essentially is brought light to the cell
base meat industry and movement and so
we really foresee or try to foresee what
the future might hold and you know I I
have really hoped it it's a priority as
as a venture fund to invest in good
people and we do that we have some of
the most incredible founders yes there's
this process of like due diligence of
screening the both the science and the
entrepreneurs themselves to see if they
can become leaders then you bring them
into batches
i didn'ti bio
or about like 12 it's 12 to 15 about
yeah every six months you're doing one
of these and then they get they get a
quarter-million dollars and for 5 or 4%
of less than 8 percent of the equity and
then they accelerate with your
connections your mentorship networks
your wet lab in downtown San Francisco
and they just like try and go as fast as
possible and yeah those six months yeah
yes hopefully to be able to raise their
their next round after at the very end
and you've had over a hundred of these
yes 111 now companies that we have
invested in the enterprise value is
currently at one point four billion
dollars and we've done this in four
years they've raised over 270 million
dollars and we've invested in over 40
percent female founders yes it's quite a
great number so we're very proud of the
work we're doing and we are going to
continue to grow and build much greater
vigor and then who are some of the other
organizations because we did the cell
based meet what are some of the other
ones okay so some of the things that
light up my life right now I've always
been a big fan of the wood without trees
Lynne Grove is the company they
have found a way to turn flax into an
old wood style material it's pretty cool
we have a bio material such as plant
based plastics it can be eaten most
recently we had a Jean indigo dyeing
company called tinctoria m-- and i don't
know if you're aware but currently the
denim industry or denim process of
dyeing jeans is very toxic and so
they've patented way of doing it in a
non toxic what process and so then we've
had let's see cell-based pork we made
the world's first pork sausage from
Selva pig named Jesse and we've had
synthetic wines and whiskeys we've made
you think of some of our other food
companies a lot of plant-based proteins
so we look at the future and we think
about when there may be a shortage for
protein how can we create new avenues
for a supply chain of plant-based
protein or protein that's alternative
totally
right now yeah biology is this massively
undiscovered lineage of evolution that
is so baked into us as humans but the
central dogma of biology just cells in
general and DNA and RNA and all the
complexity there and proteins and what
that actually means for being able to
apply it for the energy industry the
healthcare industry the food industry
the all these different industries and
so this is hypothesized to be like a
hundred trillion dollar industry over
the next I don't remember like hundred
twenty nine years only twenty five years
something crazy like that yeah yeah so I
mean traditionally when you think about
biotech you think about therapeutics and
drug development and I think one of the
things we've done really well is we're
helping to bring the idea that biotech
really can affect industries across the
board and simply by investing in you
know eight different sectors you know
from that that will impact climate
change food supply chain you know unique
Diagnostics sorry biomaterials you name
it like it's it can affect every single
aspect of our life and so we have so
traditionally when you think about
biotech it's like millions of dollars
are being poured into these big
investments of drug development or
therapeutics but we're giving scientists
the chance to really prove an idea and
build their prototype and get them the
space and the resources to to prove it
and so it's really allowing these people
who who have out their ideas to come and
and show that maybe there is a
possibility impact
yes across all those industries and also
to
to do things like more readily extend
our longevity and identify pathologies
as they're developing in our bodies and
and that's a big one so being able to be
more creative for longer in our lives
another one is our ability to you know
tackle some of these greatest
sustainable development goals on the
planet let's um I'm really proud of Indy
bio I'm really proud of all da
entrepreneurs it's been such an honor
being able to come in and interview them
on their demo day we have if you guys
look at Indy bio to search for that on
the channel you'll see just all of these
different interviews that we've done
with the founders and that could be a
great way for you guys to get inspired
or get further engaged in what in what
organizations like Indy bio and all the
companies are doing let's stay on that
on this idea of C Nobel development and
how Indy biosea and how that's such a
central part of your ethos you know we
find ourselves as stewards of the planet
after this long period of evolution and
it's this big grand experiment that's
happening and we have to do things like
you said at the beginning we have to
tune in word to go inward there's a line
with this higher self and help other
people do that and build that more
cohesive social fabric what has been
your relationship with source so there
are days when I am very connected to
source of my Higher Self then there are
days when I'm not as I'm sure that's the
case for many people when I am in
alignment when I do feel connected I
feel that I'm in service to my work I've
in service to a something that is
greater than me and it feels
I've been flow it feels a lot easier
than having resistance that who I have
to do this and if I don't do this
good it's it comes through me and so
that is my relationship with source mmm
love that doesn't feel like being forced
or half dues but it just feels like flow
yeah yeah I love now within that
relationship how do you identify these
moments of choice because you have these
we all have these bifurcating moments of
oh should I go on a four hour hike or
should I go and spend four hours on my
work and like which one's gonna help me
more with my long-term life outcome how
do you figure out what to do in those
moments mmm so it is a moment-to-moment
choice and part of consciousness or
becoming conscious is the awareness that
you have this choice and that it is on a
momentary basis and so when you begin to
live your life with that awareness
you're much more present and so it's in
that presence you are aware of say your
Higher Self and then the voice that's
always chattering and you can make the
distinction of well actually I'm going
to tune in to what's really true for me
what feels real to me what feels best
for me and you're living more
intentionally than in the moment and
you're making choices that are
intentional that are in service your
higher good to the higher good of those
around you and it's it's that
intentionality that makes a difference
and do you believe that we have free
will or is there some determinism that's
at play as well honestly I don't know
that's a debate mm-hmm then we could we
could be sitting here for a while on
that to be yeah how does it feel for you
I like to think I have free will you
know but who knows you know there's a
variety of influences around me from the
media to the subliminal messages I'm
getting which I'm like actually think
you know this is really my idea who
knows yeah especially since you're in
indie bio and in biotech you know what's
going on in your gut and was like so so
much ancient lineage happening in your
gut and that relationship with your
heart and your brain and what you're
actually yeah there's the bull biology
side of this
yeah these tens of trillions of cells
that are put together to form you yeah
what is you where is that I yeah yeah
how do you how do you deal with the
relationship between the illusion of the
eye and then you know you become the
drop with the ocean and you can you love
that process we all love that process
but then you also have have to become
the drop in the civilization again to
function how do you how do you work with
that process so again I think it's the
journey and we're all here on our own
special journey and we're all
experiencing life as as it is the the
movement between the eye and the drop of
the ocean the eye and the drop of the
ocean and we're all in our different
speed of going through that realization
that remembrance and so that's how I
look at it is just like I'm just on my
journey and you know many of us are
trying to find our just trying to find
our way home you know but then we
remember hey we already are home it's a
it's the
floo do you think or feel that there are
forces that are at play on the planet
that are you know past the
three-dimensional physical reality that
are at play on the planet well I think
Nature has a big role yes
nature is definitely alive all around us
and intelligent and conscious and but we
are part of nature so that does not
discount us and so do I think there are
forces beyond the three-dimensional
reality that we experience yeah
absolutely and then your close
relationship with indigenous wisdom as
well as ours I like to know vibe with
you on do you feel like our disconnect
from nature and source is the reason why
we have all these issues in our society
hmm yes well it starts with
disconnection with self and then from
disconnection with self all that if that
is around us and again if i if i zoom
out and I look at all of us on our
individual journeys you know we're all
on a path of saying healing or letting
go or becoming learning how to become
more presence or accept more present or
accepting of ourselves and of the life
we've we're living and so do I think
collectively we will become this
organism that is you know rising to the
occasion to fix things on the planet I
don't know all I know is in my personal
journey that the more I connect with
self and the more I connect with nature
the more aligned I feel with my higher
self and my super intelligence and it
allows me to be more present and more in
flow and that's all I can do on my
journey here
if the spirit is not fragmented if it's
hole with itself and with its connection
a source and we can inspire that in and
others then we can heal ourselves heal
our society ramp ourselves up in the
direction of prosperity I mean we've
been looking at this for thousands of
years this is the age-old question of
you know how can how can you one become
conscious right it's in all religions
it's like how do we remember who we
really are and so if you know people do
say become awakened and and they change
the current state of this planet that's
great
but do I think it will happen is that
your question yeah let's go with that
okay it could but again it's it's for me
I don't expect it all I know is what I
can can be responsible for and that is
myself and so I do see a lot of
destruction I see a lot of darkness
around me I see a lot of you know things
that I don't have control over but I
feel that I'm able to just when I when I
focus on myself and going with it and
listening to that voice as long as I'm
doing the healing and the letting go and
the practicing the forgiveness that that
will help my immediate community and
surroundings and that's what I will do
what I can do so I don't I didn't
mention this but I had a near-death
experience three years ago which I went
into a coma for a few days and had a
very profound experience in which I did
have a glimpse of what perhaps would be
happening beyond life
to death and was really left with a
sense that I need not worry about death
that was nothing to fear and that you
know we like to make things very
complicated for ourselves or at least I
did and the essence of life is is
simplicity and it's peace and joy and
love and we certainly come here with a
lot of stuff to unpack and make things
very complicated and so as I have gotten
older I just try to simplify as much as
possible so on a moment-to-moment basis
being closer to joy peace and love and
simplicity and that helped that being
brought more to your attention through
your near-death experience that death is
something to not fear mm-hmm live simply
my child yes yes and you know sometimes
I don't talk about this much because
this experience much because it was my
own experience and I think that we're
all going to learn what we need to learn
while we're here it's it's not my job to
tell people what I think happens to you
after your diets it's your your own
experiences it's like you're entitled to
what do you think is the relationship
between good and evil
well is it darkness and light you can't
have one without the other there's this
full spectrum or they both creations of
source mm-hmm good and evil me depends
how you define that I mean it's all
source isn't it some said that that evil
was based on the creation of human
ignorance
so caused by that it's interesting ya
know
what is the grand meaning of all of this
I love this show and I love the
questions you're asking because they're
so good it gives me the opportunity just
go off out there what is the meaning of
this grand experiment there is no
meaning Alan we are meaning making
machines we are always looking for
meaning but there is no meaning and
that's okay
so no inherent meaning then we create
the meaning through our adventures of
consciousness I think so so are we in a
sense these paint strokes are these
grand notes in this symphony or this
canvas of creation and we just express
ourselves artistically that brings us
meaning perhaps yeah again this is my
own opinion let's I don't claim to know
anything brought about the universe but
I do feel personally that you know it is
what it is
that's my favorite line is
does it feel like were alone in the
cosmos hmm well I do not feel alone in
the cosmos ever I have never felt like I
was alone in the cosmos I was just at
Wilbur yesterday looking up at the stars
a very vast night sky and I was just
feeling very happy because I did not
feel lonely at all and it would surprise
me if we weren't
there seems to be something special
about consciousness and about the humans
and maybe there is some sort of a deeper
purpose to extend this this light
further out into the cosmos and have
hundreds of billions of humans being
creative and experiencing conscious so
that may be the one opinion of someone
but it's not my opinion I think humanity
may be getting ahead of itself and I
don't think Humanity is any less special
or more special than on other species on
this planet mm-hmm as in the inner
experience of an insect with just a
couple hundred neurons as I think we may
give ourselves more special preference
than we need to know whether I'm a tree
or an insect or cow like it's all part
of part of the part of nature and I
think humans yeah I haven't figured this
one out yet we have a lot of hubris and
if we can call that a little bit and
realize we're more interconnected with
nature and with all the other species on
the planet
yes thumbs up also though we have this
ability to do just absolutely insane
stinks on this planet it's a bean now
stewards it gives us maybe a little bit
more of a like this species does have
somewhat more weight on its variable
than the other species that are not able
to just drastically change the future
trajectory
yes so as a species since we do have
more choices to steer our future why not
make good choices why does this feel
like a simulation ever sometimes yes and
I won't go into why I say this but I've
often I never understood the matrix
until recently in the last few years and
yeah if it is a simulation great you
know make it a great simulation maybe a
fun one make it one where we're doing
incredible things on this planet it's
not okay well not so it's not yeah I'd
want to be playing the best simulation
for sure the hardest one like the one
with the most like you have to rise to
the challenge in this one and that's
kind of what it feels like it's like
beautiful and peaceful and loving and
simple as life is there's like a lot of
complex things that we need to work on
and solve and so it's kind of like that
so you want to you want to be in the
best simulation yeah I get it
I I just I'm happy that I'm in this body
I'm happy that I have senses to
experience life as it is through you
know seeing and hearing and talking and
the other beautiful things that Earth
has to offer and all the fun things
there are to experience and I try to
live within that realm of consciousness
as much as possible to perpetuate that
to continuously create that around me so
whether it is a simulation or not I I
just know that my time here in this
particular dimension this earth space is
is one to be enjoyed immensely yes and
what would you say is the most beautiful
thing in the world love love love and
connection being connected to life being
connected to the cosmos and being
connected to each other that's the most
beautiful thing
what does that feel like for you hmm
when I am connected to the cosmos as I
was yesterday sleeping under the stars
it was just this feeling of I'm held I'm
loved
all is well when I am connected to
another human when I'm connecting other
plants animals it's this feeling of just
sweetness and then as people around
world are aiming to unleash their gifts
forward they're aiming to help have
their journey talked to the rest of the
world and potentially endeavor into cool
things like unleashing biotech to solve
some of these greatest challenges around
the world what would maybe be something
for those that are wanting to like share
their journeys and like start these
these organizations like what would be
something that people could to take on
from your advice to like to get more
well my advice is if you're going to be
in service to something greater than
yourself don't make it about you make it
about what you're in service to and you
know it is important to share your voice
it is important to be seen and heard but
you are a vehicle for for the service
and for the good and to not get caught
up in that illusion that it may just be
about you
this is why I love you so much why so
good it's so good oh we're in service to
the grander vision not about us then
people can sniff that out too you can
like sniff that out about people are
they there for the ego and the fame and
blah blah or are they there for the
actual vision impacting people you can
literally sniff that yeah
then young people are able to sniff it
out even faster rates so you can't trick
young people they'll sniff you out fast
Wow Maya thank you so much for coming on
the show thank you for having me I'm so
happy we finally got a chance to make it
happen
great yeah and I appreciate it yeah all
right are identifiying cracking perverse
incentives event where you're a panelist
was super fun to just like she's like
this needs to happen it's long overdue
so I'm glad that that it did and I'm
very proud of you I'm very proud of all
of your great impact that you've brought
forward and that you've shared on our
episode thank you everyone
tuning in thank you so much we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also check out the links in the bio
below check out the links to my trigger
links to indie bio as well check those
links out also take the some of the
inspiration that my was able to
communicating go and share with your
friends or families co-workers people
online talk more about journey talks
about your connection to the divine and
about unleashing your gifts forth and
about using biotech as such a powerful
technology to solve some of the greatest
world challenges and support the artists
the entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders
the organizations around the world that
you believe and support them and help
them grow you can find simulations links
in the bio below you can find our
patreon link our cryptocurrency link you
can find the link to our PayPal down
there you can design cool merch and get
paid all those links are below and also
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
we love you very much thanks for tuning
in and we'll see you soon